elle a presque tout d'une grande mais
cette maisonnette est invisible à l'oeil
nu microscope obligatoire pour faire le
tour du propriétaire
posé sur le bout d'une fibre optique de
la taille d'un cheveu découpé sur une
membrane de silice d'un micron puis
plier assemblée est soudé cette maison
est le symbole d'un savoir faire
technologique de pointe
mise au point par l'équipe de
nanorobotique de femto-st avec un
objectif ambitieux faire toujours plus
petits ont fait énormément de recherches
sur tout ce qui est l'assemblage la
robotique la commande à des dimensions
ultra précises pour essayer toujours de
repousser les limites de la fabrication
des objets quand on réduit la taille des
objets ont réduit leur encombrement on
augmente leur précision on diminue le
temps de réponse et ont diminué
l'énergie mise en jeu donc on est dans
tout à fait dans la course
aujourd'hui aux équipements plus
performants si la maison est la vitrine
l'exploit des chercheurs c'est la mise
au point d'un robot capable de
travailler sous vide avec une telle
précision et dans ce domaine les progrès
sont encore à venir
on déplace progressivement nous la
frontière de la robotique en a on était
arrivés jusqu'à un dixième de millimètre
lors de la création percepteur aux
motifs en 2011 la matinée put encore 10
fois en dessous il ya encore beaucoup de
marques parce que si on compare à la
particule minimale qui est l'atome
on a encore beaucoup beaucoup de 2 on a
encore au moins cinq vingt quatre ou
cinq marches à franchir avant d'arriver
à cette limite ultime
donc il ya potentiellement effectivement
encore beaucoup de miniaturisation
possible sur des domaines applicatifs
qu'on connaît à la guerre pour l'instant
pas du tout pour les industriels du
futur cette technologie ouvre un monde
d'innovation pour des centaines
d'applications capteurs routine
microchirurgie ou détecteur
environnementaux plus petit plus
sensibles et surtout plus économes en
énergie